I'm really curious about your views
about well what what post-modernism is
first of all I know you you've
identified it with the with the general
tricksters Derrida and Lucca and
Foucault and Foucault in particular
you've talked about but I'd like to know
what you think about post-modernism and
also why you think it's been so
attractive to people
well my explanation is that there is no
authentic 1960s point of view in any of
the elite universities rather the most
liberated minds of my generation of the
1960 did not go on to graduate school I
witness this with my own eyes I saw
genuine Marxists ok at my college which
was the State University of New York at
Binghamton upstate New York Harper
College which had a huge cohort of very
radical downstate New York Jews ok who
in fact the Harper we used to be called
Berkeley East so I saw genuine
passionate Marxist with my own eyes they
were not word choppers they were not
snide postmodernists right they were in
your face aggressive they used the
language of the people they had a
populist and energy Hey
they dressed working class they were non
materialistic ok these are people who
lives by their own convictions they were
against the Graduate School so anyway
when I when I just went on to graduate
school and and it became known that I
was gonna go to Yale I was confronted by
a leader of the radicals on campus in
broad daylight in front of everyone who
denounced me for he said grad school is
not where it's happening you don't you
don't do that if you have to go to
graduate school you should go to Buffalo
now I had applied to the students to a
SUNY Buffalo because the great leftist
critic Leslie Fiedler was there who had
a huge impact on me he's probably
created created identity politics but
without its presence distortions and
Norman Holland the psychoanalytic critic
was there I wasn't very happy to have
gone on to Buffalo but I needed the
library Yale so I continued on to yeah
there were no radicals in the in the
graduate schools maybe from 1968 to 72
when I was there there only one radical
Todd Gitlin ok
to have a career success the the actual
radicals of the 1960's made either when
off dropped out of college and went off
to create commune or they were taking
acid and destroyed their brains now I
have also written about that the
destruction of them of the minds okay
from the most talented members of my
generation through LSD it was going on
all around me right no thoughts what's
happened is the actual legacy of the 60s
got truncated the idea that these post
structuralist and post modernists are
heirs of the 1960s revolution is an
absolute crock okay
what they represent as Foucault shows
else Foucault said okay that the biggest
influence on his thinking came was
Samuel Beckett's Waiting for Godot okay
which was a post-world War two play
written in Paris that was about the
disillusionment and nihilism experienced
after Hitler went through occupied
France and all of Europe was in ruins it
had nothing to do though what was in
Waiting for Godot has nothing to do with
the authentic legacy of the 1960s which
was about genuine multiculturalism a
movement toward India toward Hinduism a
transformation of consciousness through
psychedelics which I did not take but
which identify with totally through the
music etc right it was a turn toward the
body it was a turn towards sensory
experience came not this this word
chopping thing and it's like cynical
removal from actual experience right
that French import okay came in okay to
the graduate schools it did not affect
any genuine 1960s person the real
nineteen sixties Revolution was about
young it was about a way of seeing the
cosmos in mythological terms and the
Union contribution went on into the New
Age movement of the 1970s aside from the
universities right so who took over the
universities were these careerists
okay I saw them with my own eyes I saw
what happened I saw I was at Yale when
Derrida was being shipped over granted
to to address or the you know the the
students there as students and the
faculty and I and I said to a fellow
student after hearing one of these guys
speak it wasn't Derrida it was
it was another one of the theorists I
said they are like high priests
murmuring to each other this this was an
elitist form from the start okay it was
not progressive it was not revolutionary
it was reactionary it was a desperate
attempt to hold on to what had happened
before the 1960s sensory revolution
open-toe this post modernist thing gay
this thrashing okay of of the text this
it is this encouragement okay of a
superior and destructive attitude toward
the work of art we're going through it's
okay
primly with red pen in hand finding all
the evidence of sexism check racism
check homophobia check that is not the
empathic emotional a sensory based okay
revolution of the 1960s I I am sick and
tired of these people claiming any kind
of mantle from the 1960s they're frauds
these people are what happened in the
1970s was a collapse of the job market
in academia
all of a sudden jobs were scarce and
this thing was there the new and
improved and shiny thing okay to be a
theorist
okay people seized on everything it was
institutionalized right and I it's in an
enormous betrayal of the 1960